so if you've got that mayan calendar
sitting in your living room you know
we've got about 10 more months before
everything goes to hell so when all the
electricity is gone and we're fighting
for water and gasoline pretty much this
is going to be your only tool for
survival this is Gerber gears survival
series / rain it comes with a full tang
a 13 inch curved blade and has really
solid construction with a rubberized
grip so things get wet things not going
to go flying out of your hand the
survival series praying is my favorite
blade because the full tank construction
gives it a really even weight and a
really good swing feel so the zombie
comes up on you you can really get right
into his guts so if you really need to
do a lot of damage or you just want to
chop a lot of wood the camp axe to is
gonna be the one for you it's got most
of its 34 ounces in the head and it's
lightweight nylon handle means you're
basically power swinging at every single
time kind of like a front-loaded
softball bat and the hammer on the back
makes it a really versatile camping tool
this is the gator machete Junior it
weighs about 14 point 3 ounces comes
with a nice saw on the back of the blade
and has a great gator grip for use
during rain or anytime it's wet the
things not going to fly out here here
it's probably my least favorite out of
the three because the blade only goes
right into here in the handle and it's a
little wobbly and it's lightweight but
it feels a little flimsy but for twenty
bucks you're going to be getting a lot
of
you
you
you